merci d'être avec nous frédéric encel en
direct sur rtl france à l'heure c'est
dire que présage-t-il les présages de
pas grand chose
je suis peut-être un petit hautes
limites en vous disant mais ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'entre israël d'une part le
ramasse d'autre part on assiste depuis
hier à l'est une grosse quinzaine
d'années à une espèce de trêve
permanente
ou en tout cas un conflit de très très
basse intensité dont les ressorts sont
quasi platement un terme
je veux dire par là que lorsque détails
et/ou est en campagne électorale il
tient des discours de matamore en
promettant laitière foudre et sur le
ramasser l'invasion de la bande de gaza
il en fait rien lorsque le ramasse de
son côté craint une reprise des
négociations entre israël et le yen ou
lorsque le train la concurrence du jihad
islamique au sein même de la bande de
gaza et bien eu certes quelques
roquettes
voyez mais en réalité depuis maintenant
une dizaine d'années on a pu assiter à
d'un véritable conflit et d'ailleurs je
dise dizaine d'années mais en réalité il
s'est produit
les élèves de l'ulis de relever
davantage de dérapage que de véritables
guerres entre les entre les deux camps
aucun des deux camps c'est exactement ça
d'abord parce que vous avez il se force
à ne pas bien sûr que les israéliens
vous avez dit crise sanitaire qui
franchement à cibler l'ensemble du
gouvernement ça ce premier point et
c'est vrai d'ailleurs à la fois pour les
mistraliens et pour les palestiniens
le deuxième point c'est que de
netanyahou a été réélu à l'entente des
conditions qu'on connaît bien
mais il est aujourd'hui au pouvoir pour
encore un peu moins maintenant de 15
mois et il fait face à une opposition
entre à des critiques d'ordre social
économique extrêmement dur on l'a vu
encore dadié jour quand on ramasse lui
en l'absence de négociations de reprise
des négociations entre israël et
l'autorité palestinienne
il n'a absolument pas intérêt à
provoquer l'armée israélienne dont on
sait très bien qu'elle fait toujours
plus de dégâts que ce que que ce que
rapporte un désir de roquettes native du
ramadan je crois absolument pas à une à
une escalade de la violence
alors le hamas était la semaine il y
avait des mollahs israël
en tout cas avoir déjoué une attaque
terroriste a ouvert le feu sur des
hommes armés ayant franchi et en
franchit la ligne bleue avant qu'il ne
reparte du côté libanais c'est ce qui
serait là disent que le hezbollah a
démenti
est ce que c'est une étincelle qui
pourrait prendre d'autres proportions
alors là comme le conflit avec le hamas
à en rester là
alors je vous dirais que là c'est plus
sérieux etc
voilà pourquoi parce qu'on a affaire aux
groupes politico religieux est
d'ailleurs direct socio politico
religieux le plus puissant au liban
d'une part et que c'est aussi
l'instrument de l'iran dans la région
arctique à au liban ça c'est sûr
maintenant du côté du rythme là on est
quand même en général très pragmatique
je ne dis pas que ce sont de gentils
garçons jeudi que les hommes du rela ont
perdu un nombre d'hommes et de lycées de
matériel hallucinant ces dernières
années certaines compactes comme ils le
prétendent aujourd'hui pour aller
libérer un côté et ses autres âneries
mais pour défendre bachar al assad en
syrie n'a rien à voir avec israël voyez
est derrière fouda on retrouve un régime
iranien qui là encore est composée
souvent de fanatiques mais rarement
d'imbéciles qui savent parfaitement que
le rapport de force mais pas en leur
faveur
face à israël quant aux israéliens vous
l'avez d'ailleurs je vous aurais notre
relation ils auront eux ils ont effectué
des tirs de semonce on est en réalité
n'a pas su que plus grave dépression
2006 une espèce de gigantesque escalade
façon et vous au maire donc là encore je
serai relativement prudent en ce qui
concerne le plan américain pour le
conflit israélo palestinien il ya des
diplomates de l'union européenne qui ont
appelé justement l'union à prendre des
mesures applicables ou contre israël ça
veut dire quoi que pour l'instant on
condamne uniquement oralement alors vous
savez que l'union européenne est
extrêmement divisé sur la question
proche orientale
c'est en particulier vrai sur le conflit
israélo-palestinien sur cette question
en particulier
sachez que les autres années on fait
maintenant on quasi systématiquement
adopté les trois votes possibles tour
contre et 1 abstention
autrement dit il n'ya aucune unité
européenne sur cette question là donc
évidemment les cours des relations mais
critique ne seront que verbale fasse ses
premiers points le deuxième point
mais ceux qui vont perdre l'annexion qui
avait été annoncé et je le répète dans
les discours de matamore électoraux
netanyahu ni qui en réalité assez vite
du tout premier julien comment il savait
une strictement rien passé comme entre
deux shows dijon avait annoncé donc
l'union européenne avait critiqué la
possible annexion de la bande de
territoire notamment autour de la vallée
toujours da par israël et ça ne s'est
pas fait du coup ça fait flop est
aujourd'hui franchement je crois que
l'essentiel des diplomates de au sein de
l'union européenne et ce notamment vrai
pour l'europe orientale en général
favorable à israël ont d'autres chats à
fouetter
merci il faudrait que hans a d'abord
répondu à nos questions et d'avoir
étendu sur rt france rappelle
géopolitologue est maître de conférences
à sciences po paris